if you had to give Trump one piece of
advice what would it be
resign hi I'm Al Gore I'm here to have
an important conversation with you about
the climate crisis and how we can solve
it global warming which I call the
climate crisis is by far and away the
most serious crisis we face we're
putting still a hundred and ten million
tons of manmade global warming pollution
into the sky every day it's a big planet
but that's an enormous amount of energy
and it's driving temperatures up it's
warming up the oceans and disrupting the
water cycle melting the ice and raising
sea levels creating droughts and
disrupting agriculture so it's a huge
issue the large carbon polluters have
put more than a billion dollars into an
effort to try to deceive people into
thinking it's not real they've taken the
same PlayBook that was pioneered by the
tobacco companies when they hired actors
and dress them up as doctors and put
them in front of cameras to falsely
reassure people that the consequences of
smoking cigarettes were non-existent
it's deeply unethical of course women's
suffrage the civil rights movement the
anti-apartheid movement
more recently the gay rights movement in
every one of these it's been young
people who have been in the vanguard
with the passion and energy and
commitment to really drive the movement
forward when enough young people put the
pressure on and and do it passionately
then the laws begin to change diet is a
personal choice but I've been a vegan
for five years now we have to walk
before we can run and I concentrate on
solutions to the climate crisis that I
think can be advanced quickly and I know
how passionately people feel about
cheeseburgers and steaks and the various
things that I use to eat
I think the present government should be
doing a whole lot more to solve the
climate crisis the UK
is gonna have real trouble meeting the
commitments that made under the Paris
agreement I notice the pledge to phase
out the internal combustion engine
vehicles by 2040 but you know India is
doing it 10 years faster than that
resigned learn about it empower yourself
with knowledge go to see the new movie
An Inconvenient sequel truth to power
it'll tell you everything you need to
know about the climate crisis use your
vote and as a citizen you have the
ability even if you're not yet old
enough to vote to influence the
political leaders that are supposed to
be representing you and not representing
the lobbyists and polluters